[Music]
thank you
my name is pankajuk I need the Google
Cloud business unit for LTI mindtree
today we're going to talk about a very
interesting topic very close to many of
our hearts uh you know many of us uh
have in the recent past
setup Enterprise data warehouses
Enterprise data platform
a lot of Empirical research has been
done in the past few years on how
important data strategy is
to your business strategy and how it
actually creates true differentiation in
the markets
um
and many of you who and many of our
clients have actually set up these
Enterprise data warehouse platforms
and
and they spent a lot of energy doing
that today what we want to do is we want
to actually expand the aperture of your
strategy in two different ways
and we talk through that a little bit
and we will actually you know with me I
have uh
actually he leads the
the data and analytics practice for LTM
entry
and we also have a niche Anish actually
is the CIO and CDO for
genius bank and he has a very very
interesting story to tell us which
actually kind of will cement the
thoughts we're going to talk about
so these are the two these are the three
of us uh you know my picture is five
years old so I think you should be able
to figure that out
um actually maybe 10 years old so so
that's us
so
so now let's talk about the and we'll
talk about the two two ways to expand
their per so let's just start over the
first thing
so this is uh as you can see in the
picture this is actually Mount Everest
so there was a research done by the
British medical journal about six years
back
of all the fatalities that happened from
1921 to 2006 on Mount Everest
192 people died on Mount Everest
between 1921 and 2006.
what was most interesting was that 56
percent of those people died after they
had ascended the peak of the Mount
Everest which is 29 000 feet they got to
the 29 000 feet they celebrated and I
think they kind of forgot that they had
to get down or they actually didn't plan
for getting down uh if you know a little
bit about Mount Everest or any other 8
000 8 000 feet mountains uh the death
zone starts at 26 000 feet
so as people were starting to get down
56 percent of the people actually
who died actually died died when they
were getting down
so it's really really important to
realize that once you set up your
Enterprise dataway house
there's a lot of stuff to be done so you
need to celebrate of course but you have
to think of the life after
very very important so that's the first
aperture we're going to actually talk
about so think ahead
once you do that once you set up your
Enterprise data warehouse platform think
ahead think of the life after
so that's your first
aperture of expansion of the aperture of
thinking when you when you think
president Warehouse strategy so that's
number one
now I'll talk about the second thing
as you guys see this beautiful animal is
a dragonfly
there was
there's a lot of research being done on
the hunting success rate of animals
so if anybody wants to take a guess how
much is a the hunting success rate of a
tiger
I'll give the answer it's actually 15
percent
how much is a hunting success rate of a
lion or a pack of lions lions or
lionesses hunt in packs
it's 25 percent
peregrine falcon falcon which actually
is a very very bright and the fastest
one of the fastest birds in the world
they actually dive down they actually
dive down and then they actually they go
for the kill and they actually shoot
back up again they are hunting success
rate is 47 percent
you look at all the animals in the
animal kingdom the hunting success rate
will range from 15 percent to
to the top of the pack is the is the
wild dogs it's 67 percent
there's one animal which actually stands
out and that is dragonfly the hunting
success rate of a dragonfly is 95
percent
now I'm why am I telling this to you
I'll tell it to you in a second but you
know but it's just very very intriguing
so actually Harvard medic Howard uh
Howard University actually did some
research on
um
on dragonflies and they try to figure
out you know what's going on you know
how are they so successful
so what really happens is that a
dragonfly has a compound eye
it has 30 000 facets of where the
information comes into the brain
and it covers almost 360 degree of of
the environment around it
the information comes into the brain
it gets processed and it has four wings
and those wings work very independent of
each other so what's really happening is
the animal is wired
to be able to take information
and that information actually is 360
degree information from a whole variety
of different sources it gets processed
and the wings work independently and
therefore the dragonfly can actually
power up down left right and it can just
stay around so what's really happening
is your information is actually in many
ways
getting captured from a variety of
different sources process and and
executed on
in a very very differentiated way
now the reason this is important
is when we think of uh when we think of
our data strategy we think of setting up
the Enterprise data warehouse platform
what we forget
is the act of Thinking Beyond which is
actually think the entire Journey end to
end
think Beyond
what information are you going to get
how are you going to process that
information and how will you execute all
that information so that's the second
point I wanted to make so when you are
thinking of your Enterprise data
warehouse strategy there are two things
you need to think about
think ahead what's a life after once you
set up your Enterprise data warehouse
how are you going to actually manage
your Enterprise data warehouse after you
set it up and you have to think before
you get to your Mount Everest and
celebrate yeah you should have thought
about it do you have enough oxygen have
you thought through that or how are you
going to get down you know are you
actually going to get down on time how
will you actually work in a team or
whatever else you need to think about
but think ahead and the second thing is
think holistically think every aspect of
your entire Enterprise data warehouse
including what information are you going
to seek how are you going to process
that information and how are you going
to execute all that information
now to actually cement this I'm going to
actually invite jet is actually going to
talk about
uh how you execute to these two
expansions of aperture and then after
that I'll invite Anish who will actually
talk through a specific
very very interesting story which we
will talk about how we actually do that
so just over to you
okay
uh thank you so much for taking time in
the morning I know yesterday you all had
a very interesting Keynote and the
reason you must be wondering some of you
about starting with Everest to dragonfly
what's going on here I think the idea is
about we talk about in the data World
narratives and storytelling and bringing
to the attention of people why you need
to do the right investment I hope you
are done really reasonably good job in
terms of getting your attention about
why this session is started with some
kind of a story
uh I go with my name Jeff and I've been
in the industry for last 26 years doing
data analytics and I for many clients
over the years and I can't tell you this
is the best time for people who are in
the data professionals who are investing
in data and trying to drive for the
first time everyone is talking about how
do I really get best out of my data and
how do I drive more monetization and I'm
sure every year there is a new buzzword
one year and it's a return is the new
oil another year data monetization data
Marketplace data products I think you
name it we have gone through all of that
I think this year probably the the new
story is going to be Janai and I'm sure
each of you has seen very interesting
demosis today and some of us got a
chance preview of that much ahead of
time we were able to bring that in our
Solutions and started driving to the
clients so what I'm just taking the cue
from what Punk had started about all of
us know in the industry data Investments
been happening over the years
and there is nothing new what we are
talking about but what is new and what
is old is I'm going to quickly touch
upon today
so if
oops sorry
yeah sorry
so if you think about
there are a few things which all of us
know over the years and I think it's
always important to talk about those
basic I think my friend from my good
friend always talk about three things
important in life which is about having
a good slave good food good exercise all
of us know but uh many of us don't do
all the three regularly the same way
some of these points all of you know
it's not about you don't know or we
don't understand but over the years
there is not enough time spent on these
areas by each of us and our investments
so let me touch upon each of them in a
very clear manner the first one is about
user adoption if you heard about any
horror stories about data
implementations I think one of the big
reason is this
the user adoption people are used to use
a particular technology people who are
getting information from a particular
area suddenly we go and talk to them
about we are migrating to cloud and once
it is done everything is taken care and
they don't have enough Comfort once they
go to the new area whether it is because
of lack of understanding lack of
awareness whatever is the reason so one
of the most important is a user adoption
and evolution as the users start using
I'm sure you all agree with me they
become more hungry about the data they
would like to get information much
faster so part of whenever we think
about new implementation and new
modernization it is very important for
us to put enough effort on that
number two just getting into an
attention getting synops right
and I'm sure those of you heard about
the since implementation of cloud our
costs are gone up any of you face that
and I'm sure quite a few of the
customers went through that kind of a
journey the reason for that is maybe it
is not well understood well thought
through not an architecture is done for
the right reason maybe simply a lift and
shift kind of thing is done and also
there is some kind of a misnomer myth
people think about going to cloud is
going to give infinite scale so people
can play whatever they want people can
explore whatever they want and may not
require all of that so it's very
important part of this data
modernization we need to set the phenops
right so otherwise people tend to give
Cloud implementation or is not
successful it's nothing to do with that
cloud it's to do with the way the setup
and architecture principles has to be
right so that's the second you know I
wanted to bring it to your attention
I'm going to cover a little more deeper
not living at that headline but I just
thought that's an important aspect
the third one is about the data quality
and observability whatever name you talk
about the data is getting flooded in
each of our organizations and I'm sure
uh you all seen the same updates about
how many Zeta mobiles better miles
that's happening even in the urban
organization day to day so it's
important to have as we invest on these
areas how we are able to Leverage The
end-to-end automation of that
information if I have to give those of
you watch Keynotes today if your entire
operations you're able to get an audit
you're able to get end-to-end view you
are able to get solving those problems
in real time how good it is
and that's an area you have to think
through and each of us wanted our
investments to get zero Ops no Ops or
very less Investments on the Operational
Support so that's where data quality and
data Ops is going to be very very
critical and the only way we are going
to get users Comfort is about quality of
the data and then finally
these days more important is about
security and privacy all of us seen n
number of incidents and the regulations
and others so in a simple way I will
talk about the usability
and then the performance which include
the cost and then the quality and then
finally the privacy these are the four
big things all of us uh you know have to
really think through enough while going
through this journey and again as I
started with it's not about we don't
know but often they were underestimated
when we start our journey and most often
when you go back and root cause analysis
of a programs which were in difficult
situations by any organization you may
end up finding one of them
or you may find the implementations are
done well but over the course of time
you have written on investment is not
really what you plan for and again it
boils down to one of these things
why are we talking about all these
things
so if you think about user adoption
um those of you have any of you I'm sure
I'm assuming all of you have completed
some form of data modernization data
migration are setting up your data to
drive
why do I do that why are we investing so
much on going to Cloud why is there so
crazy about everyone
I think bottom line is in my view two
parts one is about data democratization
going to Cloud will help you if you are
a large conglomerate you're an MNC or
you're a company which is part of the
largest supply chain you can exchange
information you can share information so
data monetization is one big thing and
then naturally the next big thing is
going to be how do you really make sure
you are able to give the information
right time right place at right level of
you know light level to the people
so when we go to modernization one of
the thing which we found quite a few
times
is about you have the users who are
using the reports and there are quite a
few people who are doing Downstream
systems where you are sharing
information and there are set of people
who are your data scientists and ml Ops
engineers and others so you have a
different types of personas in your
business
and often times we realize your
modernization you are not taking care
all of them in terms of what you need to
do
so it is important for us to look at
what are the different personas and how
each of them are going to consume that
information
and it's not done properly we found many
times organizations are going through
suddenly they realize we have some
Downstream systems they're still looking
for FTP and it may sound very weird when
people are talking about Cloud Journey
but unfortunately world still has a lot
of such systems now you cannot postpone
your production go live out of the blue
saying about your Downstream system so
waiting for it so just to get your
attention it is important to have the
right personas it is important to have
you know understanding with each of them
I'm sure all of you would have seen
the nudging the users and bring making
sure users are used you know used to a
particular screen a particular
technology for last 10 15 whatever years
they've been using their reports for 10
years 15 years suddenly we go and talk
to them about start using Lookers start
using something else it's going to
create beautiful features while it may
be great for us as a technologist or as
a business people who are implementing
the programs the end user many times
feels it's not as easy as it is for them
either two reasons one probably they're
not been involved in the beginning or
second they don't have enough comfort
with usage of it so the folks one of the
things which I wanted to bring is about
we need to plan for that and we need to
nudge and we need to ensure some
Champions about it
the next one I wanted to bring it to
your attention is about the phenobs
I think if there is one area which we
have seen significant amount of interest
in last one year and this is one
while the user personas and others are
always there but synopsis The phenomena
as more workloads are going to Cloud the
Investments are doubling tripling for
the organization
and what does that mean
and I'm sure some of you would have read
IDC and bunch of other analysts talking
about 40 percent of cloud Investments
the organizations are going through
difficult simply because a huge amount
of burn is happening then what they plan
and when you plan your return on
investment that's not what has been done
so it is important to have your phenops
ahead of time and have a clear
structured mechanism
while you give Comfort to your end users
Comfort your line of business how they
can use the information but it is very
important you have a monitoring of that
and I think we need to help
and those of you tried and tested
suddenly a Big Bill is coming with your
credit card using a one of the cloud I'm
sure you all of you gone through or all
of you seen in your history
and I think that's where I again insist
each of you to think about phenops is
the area where your implementation can
be not just successful but it will
sustain for much longer term
the next thing I wanted to bring it
attention is about the data quality and
did a governance piece of it
I think often they have seen over the
years
the data quality if there is one thing
where you get a trust with your end
users
is about data quality and these days we
are no longer using Data Warehouse just
as a warehouse whenever we have a time
we will look at it today we are using
data warehouses data Lakes as a mission
critical
some of the organizations looking that
for their financial statements some of
the organization looking for real
regulatory some of them looking
real-time supply chain efficiencies some
of them looking at real-time credit card
fraud kind of thing so this data Estates
are mission critical so in a mission
critical environment you cannot be you
cannot have a situation where your data
quality it's not a complete it's not
accurate so that's where I think enough
importance has to be given not when you
are doing modernization but once you
complete modernization you may go
through your organization may go through
mergers and acquisition your automation
may go through new implementation your
organization may go through a set of new
regulatory requirements so it is very
important to have enough Focus right up
front and I'm sure all of us know there
are enough methodologies there are
enough Technologies and toolkits
available even within the gcp ecosystem
so I think a lot of investment had to be
done there again folks this is very very
underestimated during the implementation
by every organization and whether
suddenly we keep hearing about model
drift data drift and you know there are
some challenges in our system our cxo is
still very unhappy with what is
happening and we are still trying to
find out a single view of our customer
we are still trying to fuel single view
of our products all those challenges
during modernization if you're not
taking enough importance you may end up
with that so that's where it is
important to have data quality and data
governance uh in area and I'm very happy
to say today luckily a lot of AI and gen
AI is really helping us
what I mean by that is
we we used to many many years back those
of you started more than 10 years back
15 years back 20 years back we had to
literally manually capture the metadata
manually capture data cataloging and
today we can use Chennai to scan to give
our code scan your databases and
actually help you to drive your metadata
and data quality and data catalog much
better way and that's an area when we
talk about data quality we should use
the new tools and techniques to solve
the old problem data quality problem
always existed but now we have new ways
to solve that much faster but I think
that should be part of your uh you know
ecosystem
and then finally
everyone wants now a data Marketplace
and I'm sure all of you would have heard
about how we can actually make more
money by monetizing our information
now if you think about
this is where it's very important for a
data security and privacy
every organization wants to make money
from their
and I'm sure each of you would have
heard from your cxo saying our
competitor is making much more
meaningful out of the data they are
using the data to build new products
they're using the data to improve their
operation
they're using the data to actually drive
more Revenue I'm sure all of you have
heard about
and these days all of you have heard
about data marketplace where you
actually can share your information in a
Marketplace and get some users consume
it and get the data out of it the same
way you may be consuming somebody else
in the marketplace the information so
how that will connect the dots field
so again
which has been very very fascinating for
everyone to make money from this but
very little understood by most of the
organizations how do you begin this
journey am I going to share information
which is going to be competitive you
know then am I going to lose my
competitive Advantage do I keep all the
data in the marketplaces how do I get
the security and privacy of the
information in this whole journey
I think we keep hearing about if your
organization is a multinational working
in 30 countries 80 countries 100
countries these days it's become a very
very easy for every country to come out
with their own data privacy and their
own policies and it's going to be very
difficult and each of you in this room
may play A Whiter role in terms of how
do you really bring that so that's why
the data privacy and security plays a
major role in helping your organizations
to not just monetize the data but make
sure you don't get into any regulatory
hassles you're going to get into that so
in short folks uh what I could impress
you is about the four pillars which you
talked about the usability make sure
your new Investments are usable
otherwise you just dump something from
somewhere to somewhere it's not going to
bring number two make sure your Cloud
Investments on synops are super plant
ahead of time
number three data quality is the only
way with which your Investments are
going to be sustained and then finally
it is important to have your privacy and
Security in place with the amount of
challenges world is seeing now and also
genii is creating lots of opportunities
for all of us in our business but at the
same time there is lot of guardrails are
required and that's why it is important
to plan ahead of time and do this so
that your entire Investments on cloud
will actually exponentially give your
written on investment so that's some of
the things which I thought give a
perspective you and then final point
all of you would have heard about
decision support would you mind raising
your hand decision support
okay now from decision support now we
are talking about decisions augmentation
and then finally we are talking about
decisions automation
we want to reach a stage where with AI
and gen AI your data estate can start
become a decisions automation where your
company will start driving a business
transformation truly not just a lip
service or business transformation
that's what I thought I'll give some
perspectives very happy to hear some
questions later part of time but I'll
pass the mic to Anish thank you
thank you
good morning
pankaj thank you chit for setting the
stage
um so now let me add to the story with
uh genius how a genius we are looking at
data driven decisions
before getting there
let me give an introduction I am Anish
Jacob I lead technology
at genius Bank
and I will also give an introduction
what is genius bank before that I have
to talk about smpc which is our parent
so SMBC is one of the largest banks in
the world 12th largest bank by asset
operates over 40 plus countries in the
U.S it's been operating for more than
100 years primary on the commercial
business
genius bank is the retail division of
SMBC in U.S we started building this two
years back we launched our first product
and secured loan two months back next
product is ready to go which is savings
and we have like full spectrum of full
banking product for next 10 years
so
it's sometimes very rare opportunity to
build something from the scratch when we
got an opportunity to build something
from the scratch
we want to do it little differently
we want to make better product better
experience better rate
better data Insight that users can use
and make some actionable actions based
on Insight insights they receive
so when we look at
these goals
data is a critical part to that because
without proper data and enablement of
that decisioning it's very difficult for
any of us within the organization to
achieve this goal or our customers
so with that in mind
we looked at how we need to organize
this going back to Thinking Beyond and
thinking ahead we don't want to be siled
or short-sighted with our needs now
rather than how do we put something that
can scale as we scale our organization
grow or
products suits as well as customer base
so these are some of the examples on the
left side you could see that these are
the different types of decision
or use cases our users internal uses are
trying to make
from a few examples
which segment of the customer
is going to give the highest lifetime
value
which segment we should Target which
campaign is working well
if coming to fraud what is the chance
potential chance for something to be
default some customer to be default what
is a customer risk profile
there are additional fraud cases where
we want to understand
defraud patterns we also want to
minimize false positives so these are
the set of decisions
we could make with data but then if you
look how are we going to make those
decisions
there are three ways at least
um in my opinion
human intelligence
you could get access to data you could
look at the data analyze it make your
decisions through reports Etc
the other way of making decision is
actually
you have that predefined algorithms
you implement that and that algorithms
could make decisions on behalf of human
third is most interesting and you might
have heard that last
yesterday and today a lot of AI right AI
gen AI but there are multiple variations
of that so there is like Predictive
Analytics which is widely used for
decision making and now there is Gen AI
which is kind of like adding a different
flavor which is making more human
machine collaboration
so you you have these are different ways
we want to make decisions
so when we want to make these decisions
how we Design This one how do we enable
this that's the next question
so this is how we are looking
at genius
if you think Beyond maybe when you start
it is easy for one organization to do
all the Data Insights
for in their
organization
but it's not scalable
so kind of mentioned Marketplace this is
kind of a Marketplace person so you want
to
democratize data
what that means
you centralize your data
in one place
both external and internal but then you
decentralize the consumption of the data
but it needs to be governed well you
need to have God rules
you need to ensure data quality
that kind of like outlines the
importance of data quality
you want to ensure proper access control
for that data you also want to enable
flexible analytics because
when you democratize data based on the
authorization or
or the need they should be the user
should be able to get the data into a
local environment
or their own work area means not not the
machines like in in an infrastructure
where they could actually analyze the
data
they could actually model the data
and use data to make right decisions
so now
with all this in mind
this is what we have done
a genius
they decided to build an ecosystem
that supports
data centralization and also that can
support
decentralized consumption
we haven't built all of this yet we are
in the path of building some the
centralization is almost done
decentralization is actually being built
as we speak
so if we look at some examples I talked
about loans
we have multiple sources where we get
the data our core banking underwriting
App application uh processing components
we get data at customer level we get
data at account level we also get data
at transaction level we want all this
data coming to a landing Zone one place
then sequence of processes like
security encryption cleaning aggregation
transformation and then the storage
we store it to
two different formats like one is row
file format at our data Lake
and the other one is actually more
tabular format uh using bigquery in our
data warehouse
that is more accessible
and also more domain driven
we are using pretty much Google
ecosystem
in this process because
um when we when we looked at different
options we found
this ecosystem probably meet our needs
and we can scale and we could consider
other tools if we need uh if we see a
need in the future but right now we kind
of like pretty much went with uh
full
um full of Google set of tool set
um one exception probably data governs
governance we are using collibra because
that's kind of our standard across the
board
but it's well integrated with the
ecosystem
but the idea is actually like once you
have Central data through proper
governance quality
you enable this through to different
type of uses like
it could be a leased environment it
could be their own for example credit
team could have their own environment
where they could actually like get the
data analyze the data build their credit
rules
experiment
and then push into production
they could visualize that we have looker
so looker will enable you to visualize
the data we do have a Vertex AI platform
that eventually can be used to enhance
your modeling
so
we thought like this type of an
environment is easily
scalable
and also can support today we have loans
tomorrow we have savings and we are
going to have credit card different
different products when we add over the
years this model
should be able to scale and support our
needs
we probably will make uh adjustment as
we learned but the idea is actually how
do we put together a vision where we can
March towards
so
One Challenge we experienced to us like
it's a different problem it's a good
problem to have many organizations are
looking for transformation
for us a different problem we need to
build it from scratch but when you build
this from scratch
the challenge is
you're building the organization as well
then you don't
you know you're gaining the skill set
who knows the data and also who can
build the platform right this is where
like we used lot of partnership and
Professional Services to accelerate
those development that really helped so
we blend our
internal team with industry expertise
and kind of like
build one cohesive team that can
actually help us
with the build out of some of these
building blocks
which kind of like pave the road for the
future
with that I will
conclude
my session
and I think it's it's been an amazing
journey a genius just want to make a
point that we are hiring we are looking
for a lot of expertise in Google because
we are committed to investing Google
so I'll call pankaj for uh closing
thoughts
thank you
yeah uh
thanks Anish thanks so um I think uh
there's generally a lot to absorb in a
session like this and I I think let me
just simplify and just bring those
analogies back in again so there are two
things if you if you need to remember
from this session two things think ahead
think Beyond think ahead project talked
about think about observability think
about Fin Ops think how you're going to
do user adoption very very important and
then Anish brought it to life on how you
could actually bring this all together
to create the business impact you need
to create so you need to actually think
about you know what's your use case how
are you going to use
the data platform you're going to set up
and how will you actually
uh turn that into meaningful action so
those are the two things you need to
remember so if you're actually climbing
a Mount Everest celebrate when you get
to the Mount Everest but also think how
you're going to get down what the next
steps are so that's think ahead think
Beyond you know we do a lot of learning
from biomimicry I think think about a
dragonfly think about every aspect of
your data to decision Journey not just
the central data warehouse or the data
platform you're setting up
[Music]